- [Instructor] First-year
students at a certain
large university are
required to live on campus
in one of the 24
available residence halls.
After their first year,
students have the option
to live away from campus,
but many choose to continue
living in the residence halls.
Estella oversees 12 of
these residence halls.
Her department surveyed a
large simple random sample
of first-year students who live
in those 12 residence halls
about their overall
satisfaction with campus living.
Estella can safely generalize the results
of the survey to which population?
So pause this video, and see
if you could figure it out.
All right, so let's do this together.
So Estella has done,
it's a large simple random sample
of first-year students.
So let's see,
choice A is only those
students who were surveyed.
Well, no, this was a simple random sample,
and it was a large sample, so
it's meant to be indicative
of all first-year students.
You can generalize more
than just making statements
about just the students who were surveyed.
All first-year students,
but only those who live in
these 12 residence halls.
Yeah, I think this one looks fair
because you can't generalize to people
who don't live in those residence halls.
Maybe Estella oversees the
12 best residence halls
or the 12 worst residence halls,
and so you wouldn't get,
if that were the case,
you would not be able to
generalize beyond that.
Or these might be the 12
that are closest to campus
or the 12 that are furthest from campus.
So you can only generalize to people
who live in those residence halls.
All students, first-year and not,
but only those who live in
these 12 residence halls.
Well, the issue here is,
is that a second-year student
or a third-year student
might just have a different perspective,
even if they live in those,
in that same building
and we did a large random
sample of first-year students.
We didn't do a large random
sample of all people in that,
in that, those 12 residence
halls, so rule that out.
All first-year students
at the entire university,
but not students beyond their first year.
Well, this wouldn't make sense
because there would be first-year students
who would be outside of
those residence halls.
And as I already mentioned,
the ones that Estella manages
might not be indicative of where
all of the first-year students
in this university live.